non mais le sexe tarifait ça va devenir
comme l'essence le forage représente 3%
du prix à la pompe
l'accueille maintenant Gaspard Proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine on a une actualité d'une
richesse
je pense qu'on tient la semaine la plus
riche depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale
des révoltes à cause d'une taxe sur les
camions et le retour en France des mecs
de Sahel express
[Applaudissements]
quand on pense à ce que l'État a pompé
comme fric est-ce qu'il en fait
si l'État était un joueur de foot ça
serait un branleur de 3e division avec
le salaire de Zlatan
alors
passons d'autre chose nouvelle
frontières les otages ont été libérés et
oui comme disait l'autre le Mali c'est
fini
en une opération on vient de prouver que
quatre sorties sans français qui
arrivent sur les territoires coûtent
beaucoup plus cher que 2 millimètres
clandestins
Fabius a dit qu'aucun argent public n'a
été versé bon on a eu du bol parce qu'en
fait au moment où le Quai d'Orsay suit
la facture le fils Fabius rentrait de
Deauville
c'est grand prince
bon
j'ai vu la photo des otages moi je ne
comprends pas très bien enfin pourquoi
il est allé chercher les ravisseurs
je veux pas jeter un froid mais quand on
a libéré les camps les prisonniers sont
pas sortis en uniforme nazi
ils avaient l'air assez tendu moi ça je
comprends ces trois ans de captivité tu
vois il quitte la France tout Sarko ils
se font accueillir par Rolland
ils se disent c'est un coup fourré quoi
c'est pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
berger
on leur a filé 20 millions mais comment
tu dépenses 20 millions d'euros à elle
non parce que Tombouctou c'est pas la
capitale internationale du shopping
mais bon je vais dire les mecs bon ils
bouffent des dates il roulent en pick-up
il s'habillant de lit enfin que des
trucs que tu trouves ni chez Hermès ni
chez Vuitton donc tu vois pas le drame
un enfant est tombé de l'attraction des
Pirates des Caraïbes qu'est-ce qu'on
ferait pas pour dégoûter les immigrants
de l'ANPE
rumeur moyennant les subventions des
villes accueilleraient des populations
noires de Seine-Saint-Denis peu de
choses près ça s'appelle le marché des
transferts en Ligue 1
beauté une fausse chirurgienne a été
arrêtée parce que elle est soupçonnée
d'avoir injecté du ciment dans les
fesses de ses patientes et encore c'est
que le début on attend encore les
plaintes de celles qui sont fait poser
du parquet sur le front
[Applaudissements]
le Tour de France va commencer en
Angleterre bon ça c'est normal que tous
les évadés fiscaux l'Angleterre est
devenu un territoire national enfin
c'est alors chaque année le départ du
Tour se fait à l'étranger c'est Belgique
Angleterre Corse la Roumanie on hésite
encore parce que là-bas tu dis caravane
qui va s'élancer vers Paris
c'est pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est piégé femme alors une plainte a
été déposée contre Karl Lagerfeld par
une association de défense des gros
alors l'association s'appelle belle
ronde sexy et je m'assume c'était quand
même plus simple de s'appeler
célibataire et résigné
et peut-être finir par un peu d'amour
parce que c'est
on veut pénaliser la prostitution en
collant une amende de 1500 euros au
client c'est terrible quand on pense
qu'une pipe coûte 20 euros non mais le
sexe tarifait ça va devenir comme les
sens le forage représente 3% du prix à
la pompe
non mais
ce qu'il faut pénaliser c'est l'amour
l'amour cause beaucoup plus de dégâts
que la prostitution l'amour ça peut vous
faire faire des choses horribles comme
les dîners entre couple une expo sur
l'art primitif ou un concert de Stromae
cimetière alors c'est là tout ça tu sais
que c'est un moment difficile c'est pour
ça c'est moi je vais sur la tombe des
gens que j'aime je pleure alors pour
remonter le moral faut toujours faire un
tour par les tombes des gens qu'on
n'aime pas comme ça on rééquilibre moi
systématiquement je vais sur la tombe de
Balzac je jette un bouquin de marque
Lévy et je dis alors ringard
et
bien sûr certaines personnes se
demandent comment faire revenir l'être
cher c'est une question alors il y a une
possibilité ça s'appelle la taxidermie
alors j'ai vu une émission je sais qu'il
rencontrait des gens qui ont fait
taxidermiser leur animal de compagnie
c'était vraiment assez c'est bluffant
c'est pas parfait
quand tu jettes un bâton à ton chien
taxidermisé le chien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nouvelle de la soirée peut-être un
nouveau pas été franchi dans la lutte
contre la gastro ah oui il est mort
l'inventeur du kebab
alors avec la vie et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de inarritube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu